SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER AND SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEES WILL COME TO
ORDER, WELCOME. I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
BE HERE TODAY ON SUCH SHORT
NOTICE TO ATTEND THIS JOINT
SENATE NATURAL WATER RESOURCES
AND WATER AND SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEES
, INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
FINAL WATER AND WILDFIRE BOND,
KNOWN AS THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
. WILDFIRE FIRE PREVENTION,
DROUGHT PREPAREDNESS, AND CLEAN
AIR BOND ACT OF 2024. NOW
THERE'S A SAYING FROM THE
ANCIENT GREEKS THE CIVILIZATION
IS GREAT WHEN ITS ELDERS PLANT
TREES WHOSE SHADE THEY KNOW
THEY'LL NEVER SENATOR. AND THAT
ETHOS, I THINK, DEFINED THIS
COUNTRY FOR A LONG TIME. THIS
IDEA OF INVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE, IN LONG TERM
PLANNING AND THINGS THAT WILL
PAY OFF DOWN THE LINE. AND I
THINK WE'VE GOTTEN AWAY FROM
THAT IN THE RECENT DECADES. AND
THOSE CHALLENGES, THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED
BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND ALL OF THE
RESULTING PROBLEMS THAT HAVE
ACCOMPANIED IT. CLIMATE CHANGE
IS HERE, FOLKS. EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS, WHETHER IT'S FLOODING,
DROUGHTS, HEAT DOMES WITH
DANGEROUSLY ELEVATED
TEMPERATURES, EVEN HURRICANES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BECOME THE
NEW NORMAL. THE IMPACTS OF THESE
EXTREME EVENTS AND RISING
TEMPERATURES MEAN OUR COASTAL
AREAS HAVE TO PREPARE FOR SEA
LEVEL RISE AND COASTAL EROSION.
HOMEOWNERS AND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE RISING RISK OF
WILDFIRE. THIS $10 BILLION
PROPOSED BOND IS A LONG OVERDUE
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE. IT MAKES
SENSE FOR APPROPRIATE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE BOND MARKET RIGHT NOW TO PAY
FOR THESE CRITICALLY NEEDED
PROJECTS, TO PROVIDE GREATER
RESILIENCY TO OUR STATE. WE KNOW
THAT PREVENTION PAYS FOR ITSELF
MANY TIMES OVER. ACCORDING TO
THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY, $1 SPENT ON PREVENTION
RESULTS IN A $6 REDUCTION IN THE
NEXT DISASTER'S COSTS. THESE
INCLUDE SAFE DRINKING WATER,
WATER STORAGE, DAM SAFETY, FLOOD
PRESERVATION, FLOOD PREVENTION,
WATER CONSERVATION, WILDFIRE
PREVENTION, COASTAL RESILIENCE,
PARKS AND OUTDOOR ACCESS,
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE,
BIODIVERSITY, CLEAN ENERGY AND
OTHER PROGRAMS OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. ITS
DEPARTMENTS, BOARDS AND
CONSERVANCIES. IMPORTANTLY, AT
LEAST 40% OF THESE BOND FUNDS
WILL BE USED TO BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
OFFER VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
OTHER VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AS
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE, THAT WE'RE HERE
TODAY IS, I THINK, A TESTAMENT
TO THE DILIGENCE AND EFFORT OF
THE AUTHOR, MY COLLEAGUE AND
HEARING CO-CHAIR, SENATOR BEN
ALLEN, AS WELL AS OUR COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ, AND
MONIQUE LIMÓN, WHO HAVE LED OUR
EFFORTS IN THE SENATE ON THIS
BOND PROPOSAL. IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO BE A
MEMBER OF THE SENATE WORKING
GROUP ON THE BOND. I WANT TO
THANK AGAIN, SENATOR LAMONE, FOR
LEADING AND COORDINATING THIS
WORKING GROUP AND WANT TO THANK
AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE PRO TEM IN PRIORITIZING
THIS BOND. WE WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY WITHOUT HIS COMMITMENT TO
GETTING IT DONE, AS WELL AS MANY
LONG HOURS SPENT BY THE WORKING
GROUP OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS,
CALIFORNIANS, I THINK, OWE A
DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO THE RT, TO
SENATOR ALLEN, TO SENATOR LIMÓN
AND GONZALEZ FOR NEGOTIATING
THIS BOND. NOW, THERE WERE HARD
CHOICES TO BE MADE TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE GOVERNOR ON THIS BOND. I
THINK THIS BOND IS SAFE TO SAY,
REPRESENTS A TRUE COMPROMISE.
BUT AGAIN, I'D EMPHASIZE IT'S A
NECESSARY DOWN PAYMENT BOTH TO
HELP REPAIR AND REBUILD OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT
ALSO TO HELP PREPARE OUR STATE
FOR THE FUTURE. SO THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT, I WOULD TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR
BEN ALLEN, WHO WILL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE BOND AND AN
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS, AS WELL AS
HIS CO-PANELIST DOCTOR,
ELIZABETH FORSBERG. FORSBERG
PARTY. THE CALIFORNIA POLICY
DIRECTOR OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND CAL JONES,
POLICY AND LEGAL DIRECTOR AT THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER. BOTH
DOCTOR FORSBERG AND MR. JONES
ARE LONGTIME ADVOCATES FOR THIS
BOND. WELCOME. THANK YOU SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, PLEASED TO PRESENT
TODAY SB 867, WHICH IS A MASSIVE
AND COLLABORATIVE RESULT OF A
VERY SIGNIFICANT COLLABORATION
BETWEEN MANY, MANY MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY, IS
HISTORIC IN PLACE A $10 BILLION
CLIMATE RESILIENCY GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND ON THE NOVEMBER
5TH BALLOT. IF PASSED IT WOULD
REPRESENT THE SINGLE LARGEST
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC FUNDING FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. IN FACT, IT WOULD BE
THE LARGEST MADE BY ANY SINGLE
GOVERNMENT. BESIDE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S INFLATION REDUCTION ACT,
WE, OF COURSE, SAW THE NEED IN
THE PAST YEAR TO CLAW BACK
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN CLIMATE
FUNDING DUE TO THE BUDGET
DEFICIT. AND IN THAT CONTEXT,
THIS MEASURE WILL SECURE
BILLIONS OF NEW REVENUES,
ALLOWING US TO TACKLE SOME OF
OUR STATE'S MOST SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. NEXT YEAR AND FOR
YEARS TO COME. THE BILL THE BOND
PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE AND MAJOR
NEW CLIMATE INVESTMENTS FOR
EVERY REGION OF THE STATE, FROM
THE OREGON BORDER TO MEXICO,
FROM OUR COAST TO THE SIERRA
NEVADA, CENTRAL VALLEY, INLAND
EMPIRE, EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN.
IT INVESTS IN WATER SECURITY,
DROUGHT AND FLOOD MITIGATION,
WILDFIRE PREVENTION, PARKS AND
COASTAL RESILIENCE,
BIODIVERSITY, EXTREME HEAT,
CLEAN ENERGY AND SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE. CAREFULLY BEEN
CAREFULLY CRAFTED TO PRESERVE
THE LEGISLATURE'S AUTHORITY TO
SHAPE APPROPRIATIONS THROUGH THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS IN LINE
WITH THE FUNDING POTS AND
GUIDANCE IN THE BILL, WHICH WILL
PROVIDE GREATER FLEXIBILITY AS
WE LEARN MORE IN THE COMING
YEARS ABOUT THE ROLLOUT AND MAKE
CERTAIN DOLLARS ARE NOT LEFT ON
THE ON THE TABLE, SB 867
INCLUDES A FIRST OF ITS KIND
LANDMARK REQUIREMENT THAT AT
LEAST 40% OF THE BOND FUNDS BE
INVESTED IN DISADVANTAGED AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THAT
SUFFER FROM THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT, MOST SERIOUS
POLLUTION IMPACTS, AND CHRONIC
UNDERINVESTMENT. THIS IS A
REQUIREMENT DIRECTLY MODELED ON
THE JUSTICE40 INITIATIVE ADOPTED
BY THE US GOVERNMENT. SB 867
ALSO INCLUDES ANOTHER FIRST $850
MILLION FOR CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS TO HELP CALIFORNIA'S
ZERO CARBON ENERGY TARGETS
THROUGH PORT AND OFFSHORE WIND
INVESTMENTS, CREATING THOUSANDS
OF NEW SKILLED, HIGH WAGE JOBS
WHILE CONTINUING TO PUT
CALIFORNIA AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THE FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
FEW OTHER KEY COMPONENTS THE
BOND HAS NEARLY $4 BILLION FOR
WATER, INCLUDING OVER HALF A
MILLION FOR CLEAN DRINKING
WATER, NEARLY HALF A MILLION
EACH FOR WATER RECYCLING AND
GROUNDWATER STORAGE, ALONG WITH
100 MILLION FOR STORMWATER
PROJECTS, REPRESENTING NEARLY $1
BILLION IN INVESTMENTS TO SECURE
NEW WATER RESOURCES. OVER HALF A
MILLION, SORRY, OVER HALF A
BILLION TO ADDRESS FLOODS, OVER
HALF A BILLION ACROSS SEVERAL
POTS TO IMPROVE WATERSHED
RESILIENCY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE HAVE A BILLION AND A HALF IN
PRO FOR PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS FIRE
RISKS, WHICH WE KNOW IS A
MASSIVE CHALLENGE. IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE. THIS
INCLUDES VARIOUS POTS TO FUND
CRITICAL EFFORTS TO HARDEN
COMMUNITIES AND MAKE THEM MORE
FIRE RESILIENT, FUEL REDUCTION
EFFORTS TARGETING EVERY AT RISK
AREA IN THE STATE AND FUNDING TO
REDUCE FIRE RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH TRANSMISSION LINES. THE
BILL TARGETS OVER $1 BILLION TO
COMBAT SEA LEVEL RISE AND
IMPROVE COASTAL RESILIENCY,
ENSURING EQUITABLE GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION. NEARLY HALF A
BILLION IN INVESTMENTS TO
ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT. FOCUSING
ON OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THIS INCLUDES
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES, URBAN FORESTS,
URBAN GREENING, AMONG OTHER
PROGRAMS. OVER A BILLION IN
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS TO PROTECT
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES AT RISK OF
CLIMATE IMPACTS. THIS FUNDING,
TOO, IS GEOGRAPHICALLY BALANCED
AND AIMED AT HELPING CALIFORNIA
MEET OUR AMBITIOUS AND VITALLY
IMPORTANT 30 BY 30 GOALS. WE
TARGET 300 MILLION FOR CLIMATE
SMART AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS AND
700 MILLION TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
PARKS. CRITICAL INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL COMPLEMENT OUR EFFORTS TO
REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF EXTREME
HEAT AND PROTECT OUR OPEN
SPACES. AND FINALLY, AS I
MENTIONED, THE MEASURE DEDICATES
NEARLY $1 BILLION TO CLEAN
ENERGY AND CLEAN AIR PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO SPEED RENEWABLE
ELECTRIC ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS, BATTERY STORAGE PORTS,
OFFSHORE WIND INFRASTRUCTURE,
ETC. SO, TAKEN AS A WHOLE, SB
867 IS YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORLD RENOWNED
LEADERSHIP ON CLIMATE POLICY
THAT WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF,
LET'S BE CLEAR, THIS BOND
TACKLES EVERY SERIOUS CHALLENGE
CALIFORNIANS FACE FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE, THE EXTREME HEAT AND
WILDFIRES THAT WE'RE LIVING WITH
IN REAL TIME TODAY. THE FLOODING
AND COASTAL CLIFF COLLAPSES THAT
WE SAW LAST WINTER, THE
BIODIVERSITY ESSENTIAL TO OUR
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
WELL-BEING, ALL OF WHICH ARE
DIRECT IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, ALL TOPICS THAT WE
DISCUSS ALL THE TIME ON THESE
TWO RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES, THE
BILL CREATES JOBS, IT INCREASES
INVESTMENT. IT MAKES OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES MORE PARK FRIENDLY
AND LIVABLE. IT ARMORS OUR STATE
FROM THE MOST SEVERE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE, SUPPORTED BY
OVER 180 ENVIRONMENTAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCES ORGANIZATIONS
FROM WATER AGENCIES FROM
WESTLANDS TO SONOMA COUNTY,
TRIBES, PORTS, CLEAN ENERGY
COMPANIES AND SO MANY MORE. I'M
PROUD TO SAY IT HAS NO RECORDED
OPPOSITION AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR WITNESS TESTIMONY TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE BOND. THANK
YOU, WE'RE GOING TO DO QUESTIONS
AFTER ALL THREE OF YOU
PRESENTED. SO LET'S GO TO LIZ
FAUBERT PARTY. I'M ALWAYS READY.
THEN MAYBE WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC. BEFORE WE DO QUESTIONS.
WE'LL DO SOME ROLL OFF. SENATOR
DONNELLY. YEAH, WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. LIFE AS WE KNOW IT IS
AT STAKE IN CALIFORNIA. EXTREME
HEAT, FLOODING, DROUGHT, SEA
LEVEL RISE AND CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES THREATEN OUR HOME. THE
NEED FOR A STATEWIDE INVESTMENT
TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES AND
NATURAL SYSTEMS RESILIENT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IS GREATER THAN
EVER BEFORE WITHOUT
INTERVENTION. NOW, THE COST OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ESTIMATED TO
REACH $113 BILLION ANNUALLY BY
2050. IN CALIFORNIA. BUT WE'VE
REACHED THAT NUMBER MUCH FASTER
THAN ANTICIPATED. LAST YEAR'S
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS BROUGHT
RECORD SNOWFALL, INTENSE RAIN
AND SEVERE FLOODING THAT
RESULTED IN DAMAGES FOR
CALIFORNIA, TOTALING MORE THAN
$4.6 BILLION. AND CALIFORNIA IS
NOT PROVIDING THE FUNDING AT
SCALE NEEDED TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT
OF HARM'S WAY. BUDGET CUTS HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS THAT FORWARD NATURE
BASED CLIMATE SOLUTIONS, WHICH
ARE COST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
WAYS TO PREVENT MEGAFIRES
FLOODING AND FIGHT EXTREME HEAT.
LESS THAN 3% OF THE STATE'S
CURRENT BUDGET IS ALLOCATED TO
NATURAL RESOURCE PROGRAMS. WHEN
IT COMES TO STATE FUNDING FOR
WATER AND NATURAL RESOURCE
PROJECTS, CALIFORNIA HAS
TYPICALLY TURNED TO GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS. THESE BONDS
ENABLE THE STATE TO BORROW FUNDS
AND PAY THEM BACK OVER TIME
USING GENERAL FUND DOLLARS,
WHICH MAKES ECONOMIC SENSE GIVEN
THAT BENEFITS FROM THESE
PROJECTS ARE REALIZED OVER MANY
YEARS. THE HISTORIC BUDGET
SURPLUS IN 2021 CHANGED THIS
LONG STANDING ARRANGEMENT, AND
THE STATE HAD DIRECTLY ALLOCATED
LARGE SUMS OF GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS FOR CLIMATE, WATER AND
NATURAL RESOURCES. HOWEVER,
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A NEW
REALITY TODAY WITH DECLINING TAX
REVENUE AND A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
DEFICIT. THE CLIMATE FUNDING HAS
BEEN DRASTICALLY CUT, AND WE
MUST USE BOND MEASURES TO FUND
THE STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCE AND
CLIMATE PROGRAMS. SENATE BILL
867 CREATES A STRUCTURED
INVESTMENT PLAN TO PREEMPT THE
WORST EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND PROVIDE STABLE, LONG TERM
FUNDING FOR NATURE BASED CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS. THE BOND FINANCES
PROJECTS THAT IMPROVE WATER
RESILIENCE, PROTECT THE STATE
FROM CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE SEA
LEVEL, RISE IN EXTREME HEAT, AND
ENSURES CALIFORNIA MEETS ITS
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT 30% OF
BIODIVERSITY BY 2030. PROJECTS
IN THE BOND ARE DESIGNED TO
REDUCE FUTURE COSTS, SUCH AS
MAKING LEVEE REPAIRS THAT REDUCE
FUTURE FLOODING DAMAGE,
INVESTING IN FOREST MANAGEMENT
TO REDUCE WILDFIRE SEVERITY, AND
IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS THAT ALSO
ADDRESS SEA LEVEL RISE IN
COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY, MUCH OF THE BOND
FUNDING WOULD BE USED FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROJECTS PROVIDING
STATE BOND FUNDS FOR LOCAL
PROJECTS AFFECT HOW MUCH LOCAL
FUNDING IS SPENT ON THESE
PROJECTS, AND IN MANY CASES, THE
AVAILABILITY OF STATE BONDS
REDUCES LOCAL COST. IT IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO NOTE THAT THERE IS
BROAD PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR CLIMATE
BOND. RECENT POLLING DATA HAS
SHOWN THAT NEARLY 3 IN 5 VOTERS
SUPPORT A $10 BILLION BOND. THE
STRONGEST INITIAL SUPPORT FOR A
CLIMATE OR NATURAL RESOURCES
BOND FROM VOTERS IN THE LAST 20
YEARS. WE NEED A SERIOUS
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
NOW BEFORE IT BECOMES TOO COSTLY
AND TOO LATE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. AND NOW WE'LL MOVE TO
KYLE JONES OF THE OF THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER. GOOD
AFTERNOON. KYLE JONES, POLICY
AND LEGAL DIRECTOR WITH
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER. AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE AQUA COALITION
AND WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS. THANK
SENATOR ALAN FOR HIS WORK ON
INTRODUCING SB 867 AND
NEGOTIATING TO MAKE THE BOND
THAT WE HAVE TODAY, CALIFORNIA
WAS A LEADER IN RECOGNIZING THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER, BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO FULFILL THAT HUMAN
RIGHT FOR ALL. I WANTED TO CALL
OUT A FEW POTS THAT ARE WORTHY
OF THE ATTENTION THAT ARE MOVING
THE NEEDLE FOR COMMUNITIES ON
THE GROUND. FIRST IS THE POTS
FOR GROUNDWATER STORAGE,
GROUNDWATER BANKING, AND
FLOODING. I THINK TAKEN
TOGETHER, THIS WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE WORST
CONDITIONS THAT WE SAW OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS. DEALING WITH THE
WHIPLASH THAT WE NOW FACE.
RIGHT. WE ARE GOING FROM EXTREME
DROUGHT PUNCTUATED BY LARGE
AMOUNTS OF WATER, AND WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THAT WATER
IN THE GROUND AS THE SNOWPACK
CONTINUES TO DISAPPEAR. OUR
AQUIFERS ARE THE ONLY PLACE
WHERE THAT WATER CAN GO IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE SUSTAINABILITY AND A
STABLE SOURCE OF DRINKING WATER
YEAR OVER YEAR, SECONDLY, I
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR DRINKING
WATER PROGRAMS IN THE STATE, THE
2024 NEEDS ASSESSMENT DEVELOPED
AS PART OF THE WATER BOARD SAFER
PROGRAM, IDENTIFIED THAT WE NEED
A TOTAL OF $15.5 BILLION TO
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THAT THERE IS A
GAP OF $5.5 BILLION IN GRANT
FUNDING. THE WATER BOARD HAS
ALREADY SPENT DOWN ALMOST ALL OF
THE 2021 INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS
THAT WERE PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE, AND THAT WE ARE
FACING THE END OF THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW IN ABOUT
2026. SO, IN SHORT, WE'RE FACING
A FISCAL CLIFF WHERE WE NO
LONGER HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE
RESOURCES TO MOVE PROJECTS
FORWARD. AND THAT MEANS FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE WORKING
IN, THEY COULD BE LEFT WITHOUT A
SOLUTION. WE SPENT YEARS WITH
FUNDING UNDER THE SAFER PROGRAM
TO ORGANIZE COMMUNITIES,
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS AND PLACES
LIKE EAST OROSI AND TULARE
COUNTY OR ROYAL OAKS COMMUNITY
IN MONTEREY COUNTY TOWARDS LONG
TERM DRINKING WATER SOLUTIONS
AND WITHOUT FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS, WE WILL
NEVER REALIZE THOSE SOLUTIONS.
SO WITHOUT SB 867, WE COULD
POTENTIALLY SQUANDER THE TRUST
WE'VE BUILT WITH THESE
COMMUNITIES. WE NEED THIS BOND
IN ORDER TO DELIVER OUR PROJECTS
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS. AND JUST BEFORE
SENATOR DAWLEY HAS HIS QUESTION,
I THINK I WANT TO MAKE A
STATEMENT AND ASK A GLOBAL
QUESTION BECAUSE THIS IS A, I
APPRECIATE THIS BOND. IT'S VERY
MEASURED. IT'S VERY NECESSARY.
IT REALLY MEETS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. WHEN I LOOK AT THE
CATEGORIES FOR THE BOND, IT
MATCHES, MY DISTRICT PERFECTLY
FOR THE FACT THAT IT'S GROUND
ZERO FOR MANY OF THESE ISSUES.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MOST
EXPENSIVE FIRE IN HISTORY, IT'S
THE SOBERANES FIRE IN BIG SUR.
IF YOU LOOK AT FLOODING, THE
PAJARO LEVEE BREAK WAS IN THIS
DISTRICT AND THE NEED TO DO IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT WATER, CLIMATE IS
CHANGING THE WATER DRAMATICALLY,
AND AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THE DISTRICT DOES NOT IMPORT
WATER FROM ANYWHERE. AND
THEREFORE WATER RECYCLING MOST
OF THE TOP OF THE TWO PLACES
THAT, LEASES HAVE BEEN MADE FOR
OFFSHORE WIND. ONE IS OFF THE
CENTRAL COAST AND THERE IS MONEY
IN HERE, FOR PORTS, THE SEA
LEVEL RISE. I REPRESENT JUST
UNDER A QUARTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST. AND WE SAW IN
THE ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS, JUST
WITH THE RISING SEAS WHAT IT DID
WITH WHARFS, SEAWALLS, JUST
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS. AND SO
THIS IS REALLY NECESSARY, IS
THERE GOING TO BE A WAY, AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S EVEN A THE SAN
ANDREAS CORRIDOR IS ONE OF THE
UNIQUE CORRIDORS, FOR WILDLIFE
CROSSING BOTH THROUGH THE COAST
RANGE FROM THE COAST TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, NORTH SOUTH. IT
GIVES REAL OPTIONS FOR THAT. AND
I KNOW IT'S CALLED OUT IN THE
BOND. IS THERE GOING TO BE A WAY
THAT THERE'S INFORMATION THAT
TELLS US, LIKE IF WE WANT TO
TURN AROUND AND MAKE SURE WE
EXPLAIN CLEARLY TO EVERYONE IN
THE DISTRICT WHAT IS THERE AS
THEY CONSIDER THIS, IS THERE
GOING TO BE INFORMATION THAT'S
EITHER DISTRICT BY DISTRICT OR
CALLS OUT THINGS SO THAT THAT WE
HAVE A Kò THAT THAT JUST DOESN'T
RELY ON THE FACT THAT I SORT OF
KNOW THOSE ISSUES THAT THAT
PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT THE BOND AND
BE ABLE TO REFLECT OUT. YEAH, I
BELIEVE THAT THAT DOCUMENT HAS
BEEN CREATED. I MEAN, THE
CHALLENGE, OF COURSE, THROUGH
ALL OF THIS IS WE WANT TO BE AS
BIG PICTURE AS POSSIBLE SO AS TO
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN DEGREE OF
CONSISTENCY AND FAIRNESS ACROSS
THE BOARD. WE ALSO ARE ACUTELY
AWARE OF HOW EVERYONE IS REALLY
ANXIOUS TO SHOW BENEFITS FOR
THEIR OWN DISTRICTS. THROUGHOUT
THIS. BUT BUT WE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT MEMBERS WERE
GIVEN, INDIVIDUALIZED LISTS SO
THAT THEY CAN POINT TO YOU FOR
THOSE PARTS THAT ARE THEIR
DIRECT CALL OUT OR WHERE THERE'S
A VERY SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES TO GET
MONEY. AND I KNOW THAT THAT THE
WATER BOND THAT I WORKED ON IN
2014 WAS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT
WAS NOT A COLLECTION OF
EARMARKS, IT WAS A COLLECTION OF
POTS THAT WAS MERIT BASED THAT
YOU APPLIED FOR. AND I KNOW THE
SENATE WENT INTO THIS WITH THAT
BEING AN ETHIC THAT WE REALLY
WANTED TO DO. AND I SEE IT
THROUGHOUT THE BOND. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT IT'S,
YOU KNOW, IT'S WATER RECYCLING
WHEREVER THERE THAT IS THE NEED
NOT CALLING OUT INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS. I MEAN, QUITE FRANKLY,
IT'S WHAT MOTIVATED ME TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS WHOLE THING IN
THE FIRST PLACE. WHEN I THINK IT
WAS PROP 18. SORRY, SORRY, I'M
SORRY. PROP THREE. WHEN, IN
2018. RIGHT ANYWAY, YEAH, MY
NUMBERS ARE FLIPPING AROUND IN
MY HEAD, THAT, WHICH WAS A
CHRISTMAS TREE AND IT WAS
RIGHTLY, I THINK CORRECTLY
VILIFIED ON THE EDITORIAL PAGES
FOR, FOR BEING THAT CHRISTMAS
TREE APPROACH. AND WE REALLY
WORKED HARD TO, TO TRY TO
MINIMIZE THAT AS BEST WE CAN. I
MEAN, UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW,
FOR BETTER OR WORSE, THIS IS A
RESULT OF A POLITICAL PROCESS.
AND BUT WHAT WE REALLY TRY TO
STAY BIG PICTURE THROUGH THIS
NEGOTIATION. BUT THAT BEING
SAID, WE'RE VERY ANXIOUS TO MAKE
SURE THAT MEMBERS AND THEIR
CONSTITUENTS KNOW ALL THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
OUT THERE, YOU KNOW, IF WE'RE
ABLE TO PASS THIS THING AND THE
BENEFITS REALLY ARE NICELY
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE STATE, IN
WAYS I THINK PEOPLE WILL FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT. AND LET ME
ASK A FEW HIGH LEVEL QUESTIONS
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD BE ASKING THEM IF THEY
WERE HERE, AND WE WILL GET TO
SENATOR DONNELLY. WHAT'S YOUR
RESPONSE TO THOSE THAT THAT SAY
THIS BOND IS TOO LARGE AND
THERE'S A QUESTION OF
AFFORDABILITY? YEAH. I WHEN WE
FIRST PROPOSED IT, OF COURSE,
WAS 15. WE BROUGHT IT DOWN. I
MEAN, THE SAD TRUTH IS THAT AT
LEAST ACCORDING TO SOME
ESTIMATES, THE ANNUAL COST OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS GOING TO BE
$50 BILLION A YEAR BY THE MIDDLE
PART OF THE CENTURY. HARD TO I
DON'T EVEN HARD TO GET MY HEAD
AROUND THAT DATA POINT, BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY ARGUED BY RESEARCHERS
THAT THE NEED IS MASSIVE. AND I
GUESS THE THOUGHT HERE HAS BEEN,
HOW DO WE CRAFT SOMETHING THAT
IS GOING TO BE REASONABLE? WE'VE
SPOKEN EXTENSIVELY WITH FOLKS IN
WALL STREET AND PEOPLE IN THE
BOND MARKETS TO, TO, SO AS TO
CRAFT SOMETHING THAT'S NOT GOING
TO BE THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY IN NEW YORK AND WALL
STREET. YOU KNOW, WHILE ALSO
MAKING A DIFFERENCE. AND THAT'S,
THAT'S BEEN THE NEEDLE THAT
WE'VE TRIED TO THREAD HERE, BUT
AS YOU KNOW, THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE PUSHING FOR MUCH HIGHER
BONDS IN THIS SPACE BECAUSE OF
HOW BIG THE NEED IS. AND AS WE
NEGOTIATED THIS, IT WAS
EXCRUCIATINGLY DIFFICULT
ACTUALLY TO GET IT TO LAND AND
NOT JUST MUCH HIGHER. I MEAN,
PEOPLE WANTED TO SEPARATE FLOOD
BONDS. YES. WASN'T EVEN IN A
SEPARATE AG BONDS HAVE FLOOD
BOND. THAT'S RIGHT. SO A COUPLE
OF OTHER QUESTIONS. YOU AND I
WERE ON A CLIMATE WORKING GROUP
IN THE SENATE, A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, AND THERE WAS A REAL EFFORT
TO MAKE SURE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WAS A PIECE OF THIS.
HOW IS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT,
RELATE TO THIS BOND? YEAH I
MEAN, THERE'S THERE ARE, THERE'S
LOTS FIRST OF ALL, LOTS OF JOBS,
YOU KNOW, IN NEARLY EVERY ONE OF
THESE LINE ITEMS, WE'VE GOT A
REAL FOCUS ON, ON BENEFITING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
THERE'S A JOBS ASPECT TO THAT AS
WELL, YOU KNOW, WE'VE WE'VE
TRIED TO MAINTAIN FLEXIBILITY
FOR, FOR THE POTS, BUT, BUT, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE WE'VE CERTAINLY, YOU
KNOW, THE WILDFIRE SECTION FOR
EXAMPLE, THERE'S SOME REALLY
STRONG WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
LANGUAGE, PARTICULARLY FOR THE
CONSERVANCIES THAT I, YOU KNOW,
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT, SO THAT ETHOS FINDS ITS WAY
INTO ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE BOND. AND THEN A
LOT OF THE DISCUSSION OF THE
LEAD UP TO THE BOND WAS IN
RELATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER WITH REGARD TO
30 BY 30, HOW DOES THE BOND SORT
OF ADDRESS OR GIVE OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE 30 BY 30 SPACE? YEAH. SO
THAT'S PRIMARILY IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES CHAPTER. WHICH IS 1.2
BILLION. AND IT'S ALL ABOUT
TRYING TO PROTECT OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES AT AT RISK OF CLIMATE
IMPACTS, IT'S GEOGRAPHICALLY
BALANCED. IT'S ALL IT'S VERY
MUCH FOCUSED ON THE 30 BY 30.
IT'S CHAPTER. WHAT IS IT, WELL,
JUST THE BIODIVERSITY CHAPTER,
BUT IT INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
CONSERVANCIES FOR WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD, WHICH GETS
THE BULK OF IT, SOME TRIBAL
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS AS WELL,
IT'S FOCUSED ON. AND THIS
ENDLESS CORRIDOR THAT YOU
MENTIONED IS IN THAT CHAPTER AS
WELL, SO 30 BY 30 HAS BEEN WAS
WAS VERY MUCH IN MIND. AND THIS
FUNDING IS GOING TO HELP US MEET
THOSE GOALS. AND THEN LASTLY, I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A RELATIONSHIP
MANY TIMES TO FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
IS THERE A WAY OR AN ESTIMATE OF
IF THE BOND IS IMPROVED, HOW IT
MIGHT UNLOCK SOME FEDERAL MONEY.
WHAT'S THE RELATIONSHIP? DO YOU
HAVE ANY? YEAH, THERE ARE ALL
SORTS OF MATCHES. AND IN FACT,
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS, IT WAS A VERY
CONTENTIOUS DISCUSSION RELATING
TO CLEAN ENERGY, HAD TO DO WITH
ENSURING THAT WE WERE SPENDING
SOME RESOURCES THAT WOULD HELP
TO UNLOCK FEDERAL MONEY. WE MET
EXTENSIVELY WITH FOLKS WHO CAME
OUT TO, YOU KNOW, ACTUALLY CAME
FROM DC, FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY TO TALK TO US ABOUT WAYS
THAT WE COULD, WE COULD WE COULD
ACCESS FEDERAL FUNDING COMING
OUT OF THE IRA. AND THE OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE LEGISLATION. AND
THE IRA IS THE INFLATION
REDUCTION IS AN ORWELLIAN
ORGANIZATION IN IRELAND. THAT'S
RIGHT. YEAH. JUST CHECKING.
YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT, THAT'S
RIGHT. NO, I YEAH THAT'S RIGHT,
BETTER NOT JOKE ABOUT THE IRA,
BUT BUT BUT THERE ARE, THERE ARE
FEDERAL MONEY WAS WAS PART OF
THE THINKING ALL THROUGH THE
BOND. BUT ESPECIALLY THERE ARE
REAL OPPORTUNITIES IN THE ENERGY
SPACE. AND WE'VE MET EXTENSIVELY
WITH DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY FOLKS
TO, TO CRAFT THIS IN A WAY THAT
WILL MAXIMIZE OUR OPPORTUNITIES.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS
PEOPLE HAVE IS IF THIS PASSES,
HOW QUICKLY WILL IT GET OUT THE
DOOR, YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
WITH THAT FEDERAL MONEY THAT
MIGHT NOT MAKE IT REALLY FAST,
BUT IS THIS STRUCTURED SO THAT A
LOT OF IT WILL GET OUT THE DOOR
SOON AFTER? IT'S ALL ABOUT
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY, WHICH BY
THE WAY, SOMETIMES WILL
ENCOURAGE US TO GET OUT THE DOOR
QUICKLY. AND SOMETIMES IT
ENCOURAGES US TO GO SLOWER FOR
EXAMPLE, RATES GO UP AND DOWN.
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE EVERYTHING
ON SUCH A STRICT TIMELINE THAT
WE HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, SELL BONDS
IN A WAY THAT WOULD BE
DISADVANTAGEOUS FOR THE STATE
BECAUSE IF RATES ARE AT A HIGHER
LEVEL, SO THERE'S A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY BUILT IN. IN FACT,
THESE COMMITTEES AND OUR SUBS
WILL WILL BE WORKING EXTENSIVELY
OVER THE LAST FEW NEXT FEW
YEARS. IF THIS PASSES TO REALLY
CRAFT THE ROLLOUT. BUT CERTAINLY
THE YOU'RE MAKING SURE THAT WE
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF FEDERAL MONIES
GOING OUT THE DOOR WOULD WOULD,
WOULD BE A MAJOR FACTOR IN
DETERMINING THE SPEED WITH WHICH
WE, WE, WE TRY TO PUSH FOR THE
ENERGY FUNDING ESPECIALLY. OKAY
THANK YOU, LET ME SURVEY ALL THE
REST OF THE MEMBERS TO SEE IF
ANYBODY ELSE HAS ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
FIRST OFF, I WANT TO JUST, I
JUST WANT TO MAYBE DRAW A LITTLE
PICTURE. I ACTUALLY SUPPORTED
PROP ONE. WAS THE FIRST BOND I
EVER ACTUALLY PUBLICLY
SUPPORTED, WHICH WAS A RENDON
BILL. AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND, YOU KNOW, IT WAS
NEGOTIATED AND THERE WAS TALK
ABOUT STORAGE ABOVE GROUND
STORAGE. I KNOW THAT FOR WATER.
FOR WATER. FOR WATER, YES.
BECAUSE ENERGY STORAGE IS HIS
OWN THING? ENERGY STORAGE ISN'T
IT? YEAH. SO WE'LL GET TO THAT.
YEAH, SO YEAH, TÌM UP, I THINK I
THINK, I THINK, LOOK, FOR ME,
IT'S, IT'S ABOUT HOW WE DO IT,
AND IT'S WHAT WE DO AFTER WE SAY
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO, IT GETS
DONE. IF THAT MAKES SENSE. SO
HERE WE ARE, 12 YEARS WAS 2014.
I THINK IT WAS 2014 THAT WE
PASSED THE PROP ONE. HERE WE
ARE. YOU KNOW, TEN YEARS LATER
AND WE HAVEN'T PUT ONE DROP OF
WATER IN STORAGE ABOVE GROUND.
AND I WENT OUT, TOLD MY VOTERS I
SUPPORTED IT IN THIS ASSEMBLY,
VOTED FOR ON THE FLOOR. MY
CONSTITUENTS ALL VOTED AGAINST
IT. AND RIGHTFULLY SO. THEY
SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY STORAGE. WE'RE HERE.
HERE WE ARE. AND WE HAD RECORD
BUDGET SURPLUSES, MONEY
COMMITTED. WE HAD THE FEDERAL
FOLKS ON BOARD AND WE STILL
HAVEN'T BUILT SITES OR
TEMPERANCE FLAT. APPARENTLY IT'S
OFF THE TABLE NOW, BUT SITES IS
STILL A PROJECT THAT WE SHOULD
BE BUILDING TODAY. AND I THINK
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN WE'VE SEEN THE EXTREME
EVENTS, WE'VE SEEN RECORD
SNOWFALLS, AND WE'VE SEEN RECORD
RAINS AND WE'VE SEEN ALL KINDS
OF RECORD FIRE AT THE SAME TIME.
SO IT'S REALLY HARD TO GO BACK
TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND SAY,
HEY, YOU KNOW, SUPPORT ANOTHER
BOND. SO LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT
THE MATH HERE A LITTLE BIT. $10
BILLION. THAT'S 10,000 MILLIONS
WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN TO LIKE
GET IT INTO SOMETHING THAT
SOMEBODY CAN GET THEIR MIND
AROUND. WE THROW AROUND BILLIONS
AND LIKE IT'S A MILLION HERE. SO
THE DEBT SERVICE ON $1 BILLION
IS 500 MILLION EVERY YEAR. SO
THAT'S A HALF $1 BILLION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE FOR DEBT
SERVICE. AND IT COMES RIGHT OFF
THE TOP OF THE BUDGET. BUT A
BILLION IS 1000 MILLION, RIGHT.
SO YOU GOT TEN OF THOSE, RIGHT?
OKAY. 10,000 BILLION MILLIONS.
YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT I GOT IT
RIGHT. YEAH. TRUST ME I KNOW
THIS ONE. ALL RIGHT. GOOD, GOOD.
I'M MAKING SURE YOU KNOW IT
BECAUSE A LOT OF MONEY. NO WE'RE
AND IT'S IN THE AND IT'S A LOT
OF DEBT. WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE.
IT'S A LOT OF DEBT. WE JUST DID
5 BILLION WHICH IS 5000 MILLION
FOR A BOND THAT BARELY PASSED.
THE VOTERS BARELY PASSED, WHICH
IS THE DEBT SERVICE ON THAT IS A
QUARTER OF $1 BILLION EVERY YEAR
RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF OUR BUDGET.
SO YOU'VE GOT A QUARTER OF A
BILLION THERE. AND IF YOU DO 10
BILLION IN THIS BOND, YOU NOW
HAVE ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEBT SERVICE FOR THESE TWO BONDS
THAT WERE JUST PUT ON THE
BALLOT. AND THERE'S OTHER BONDS
THAT WE'RE STILL PAYING OFF. SO
I JUST WANT TO DRAW A PICTURE
AND THE EDUCATION BOND AND THE
YEAH. AND WE GOT AN EDUCATION
BOND COMING. SO I JUST WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT EVERYBODY
TALKS ABOUT A BOND. THEY THINK
ABOUT, OH IT'S NOT A TAX. WELL
IT REALLY IS. IT'S OR IT'S A
DEBT SERVICE. YOU HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF. BUT THE REAL POINT I
WANT TO GET OUT IS WHAT ARE WE
GETTING FOR OUR, OUR OUR OUR
BONDS. WHEN WE WHAT DID WE GET?
WHAT DO WE GET OUT OF THESE
PROJECTS ON TOP OF THAT, WE'RE
GETTING TAXED AT THE CAP AND
TRADE. THERE'S A WHOLE CAP AND
TRADE POT THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
TAKE CARE OF CLIMATE CHANGE,
WHICH WE'RE PAYING FOR AT THE
PUMP. EVERY TIME WE PUT A GALLON
OF GAS IN OUR CAR, OR WE FLIP
THE LIGHT ON IN OUR HOUSE. SO,
YOU KNOW, SENATOR, I, I KNOW
THERE'S A NEED, BUT AND YOU SAID
IT'S KIND OF BROAD. I ACTUALLY
LIKE IT TO NARROW IT DOWN AND
SAY WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO.
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE ACTUAL
PROJECT? I DON'T I MEAN, THE ONE
BOND THAT STANDS OUT IN MY MIND,
OR THE ONE BALLOT INITIATIVE
THAT STANDS OUT IN MY MIND WAS
THE BULLET TRAIN INITIATIVE.
THAT IS CARVING OUT LITERALLY $5
BILLION EVERY YEAR TO GO TO THE
BULLET TRAIN THAT DOES IN MY
MIND NOTHING FOR THE CLIMATE.
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
REALLY WISE ABOUT HOW WE ARE
GOING TO PITCH THIS TO
CALIFORNIANS. YEAH. SO YOU GOT 5
BILLION ALREADY PASSED IN THE
LAST ELECTION. YOU GOT THIS $10
BILLION BOND. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE AMOUNT FOR THE
EDUCATION BOND IS. ANOTHER TEN.
YEAH SO THERE'S $25 BILLION THAT
IT HAS TO BE PAID FOR OVER THE
NEXT 30 YEARS, WHICH IS DOUBLE
THAT. SO THAT MEANS THAT WE'RE
ADDING IT BASICALLY IS A DOUBLE
AMOUNT OF THE ORIGINAL BOND, THE
AMOUNT YOU HAVE TO PAY OVER THE
TIME. SO I'M SKEPTICAL OF WHAT
I'M PUTTING ON MY CHILDREN. WHAT
ARE WE PUTTING ON OUR CHILDREN?
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT $25
BILLION, 25,000 MILLIONS THIS
YEAR IN THESE THREE WE ALREADY
GOT WE ALREADY GOT A QUARTER OF
IT. WE GOT THE 5 BILLION. SO. SO
I REALLY AM WANTING TO KNOW WHAT
ARE WE ACTUALLY GOING TO GET?
WHAT WHAT PROJECTS ARE WE GOING
TO GO DO? I MEAN WE HEARD ABOUT
STORING WATER IN THE GROUND AS
AN EXAMPLE. AND I'M TRYING TO DO
IT IN SISKIYOU COUNTY, RIGHT
NOW. BUT I GOT THE FISH FOLKS
FIGHTING ME. I GOT EVERYBODY, I
GOT FARMERS THAT ARE WILLING TO
DO THIS, BUT WE CAN'T GET IT
DONE EVEN WHEN WE HAVE HUGE
EVENTS WITH EXTRA WATER. SO
ANYWAY, I JUST WANTED TO I WANT
TO ASK. THIS IS PRETTY BROAD.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF FROM WHAT
I'M SEEING, AND I'M NOT AT THE
LEVEL OF DETAIL. YOU ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS, BUT I JUST WANT
TO PUT IT OUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIANS TO KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF DEBT COMING.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE
BUDGET DEFICITS. WE'RE SEEING
BUSINESSES LEAVE CALIFORNIA AND
SOMEONE'S GOT TO PAY THESE
BILLS. AND WE'RE WE'RE STRAPPING
OUR OUR CHILDREN. SO DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ON THEM? YEAH. WELL
LOOK, I THINK THE GUIDING LIGHT
THIS ENTIRE TIME WAS FOR, FOR ME
AND FOR IN EVERY CONVERSATION I
HAD WITH THE FOLKS THAT WERE
NEGOTIATING ON BEHALF OF THE OF
THE SENATE WAS, YOU KNOW, IN
ORDER TO JUSTIFY PUTTING THIS
INTO THIS BOND, IS THIS GOING TO
BE THE KIND OF THING THAT OUR
CHILDREN 20, 25, 30, 35 YEARS
FROM NOW WILL FEEL GOOD ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WE INVESTED IN IT?
NOW, IT'S NOT A IT'S AN
EXPENDITURE THAT IS THAT IS
TRULY GOING TO BENEFIT FUTURE
GENERATIONS. THAT'S WHAT BONDS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT. IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT PUTTING IN
PLACE, YOU KNOW, BASICALLY
STARTING THE INVESTMENT IN WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, SENATOR, I'M
HAVING A HARD TIME JUSTIFYING
TELLING MY 24 YEAR OLD SON THAT
WE'RE BUILDING A BULLET TRAIN ON
THE BACK OF HIM RIGHT NOW, BUT
BUT THAT WAS THAT WAS THE SAME
STORY WAS SAID WHEN WE WERE
BUILDING THAT THIS IS FOR THE
FUTURE. WE'RE GOING TO SHOW THE
WORLD HOW TO DO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND HE'S HE'S GOING TO BE PAYING
FOR THAT. HE'S STILL PAYING FOR
IT. IF IT'LL EVER GETS BUILT.
SAME THING WITH PROP ONE. MY MY
KIDS AND SOMEDAY GRANDKIDS ARE
GOING TO BE PAYING FOR THESE FOR
THESE DEBT. AND THE ISSUE IS YOU
CAN MAKE THAT STATEMENT, BUT
WHAT ARE WE GETTING FOR IT? WE
HAVEN'T WE DON'T HAVE A VERY
GOOD TRACK RECORD OF
DELIVERABLES FOR BONDS IF THERE.
SO I'D LIKE TO SEE IT. I MEAN
THERE'S I MEAN WE CAN WE CAN
CERTAINLY THERE'S LOTS OF LOTS
OF REALLY WORTHY PROJECTS,
INCLUDING MANY IN YOUR DISTRICT
THAT HAVE BEEN INVESTED IN
PREVIOUS BONDS. WELL, I WOULD
SAY THERE IS A GIVE IT TO CALL
OUT CERVANTES, BUT THAT'S A
DIFFERENT. YEAH, I'M GOING TO
MAKE A COMMENT, BUT I'M WAITING.
AND IT WAS GOING TO. DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY IN
ANSWER? WELL I DID, I DID WANT
TO JUST TALK ABOUT THE FINANCING
OF, OF, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE I
MEAN, THE END OF THE DAY, THE
WAY THAT WE THE BEST, BOND
MANAGEMENT TOOL IS NOT TO ISSUE
BONDS UNTIL THE CASH IS NEEDED
FOR PROJECTS. RIGHT. THAT'S, YOU
KNOW, IN PART BECAUSE AS A
RESULT OF PROVISIONS IN FEDERAL
LAW, ISSUERS CAN'T SELL BONDS
AND INVEST THE PROCEEDS AT, YOU
KNOW, AT AN INTEREST RATE HIGH
ENOUGH TO COVER DEBT SERVICE
COSTS. SO, I THINK I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MENTION THAT IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN, THAN THAN OTHER
TYPES OF, OF BUDGET DEBT. BUT,
YOU KNOW, LOOK, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, THIS IS YOU CAN I MEAN,
WE CAN GO THROUGH EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF THE LINE ITEMS. SOME, YOU
KNOW, QUITE FRANKLY, I THINK ARE
STRONGER THAN OTHERS. I THINK
THERE'S LOTS IN HERE THAT YOU'LL
FIND REALLY VALUABLE. WE KNOW
WE'VE GOT MASSIVE CHALLENGES
WITH REGARDS TO WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT'S BY FAR THE
BIGGEST PART OF THE BOND, YOU
KNOW, WE KNOW PEOPLE CARE. YOU
KNOW, A TON ABOUT ABOUT THIS,
AND IN FACT, THERE'S ACTUALLY A
SPECIAL CALL OUT SPECIFICALLY
FOR WATER STORAGE. AND YOU
MENTIONED THE SITES PROJECT,
WHICH IS CERTAINLY A PRIORITY OF
THE GOVERNORS AND SOMETHING THAT
HE'S BEEN WORKING TO TRY TO
EXPEDITE, SO, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
CONVEYANCE MONEY. THERE'S, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT FOR GROUNDWATER STORAGE,
BUT THAT'S GOING TO HELP
EVERYBODY. THERE'S SAFE DRINKING
WATER, MONEY, LAND, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT WATER
RECYCLING, WHICH IS GOING TO,
YOU KNOW, FOR AREAS LIKE URBAN
AREAS, WHICH WILL DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE THE DEMAND FROM DISTRICTS
LIKE YOURS, THAT WILL HELP
STATEWIDE. BUT WE KNOW THAT
COSTS MONEY TO INVEST IN. AND
SO, SO ALL THOSE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS, I THINK WE'RE ALL
GOING TO I DO THINK YOUR
CHILDREN WILL, WILL, WILL BE
APPRECIATIVE OF I MEAN, QUITE
FRANKLY, WE'RE ALL SEEING THE
IMPACTS OF THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT FROM PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS IN VARIOUS ASPECTS
OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE'RE
ALL STRUGGLING AS A RESULT. I
MEAN, CERTAINLY LOOK AT THE
FARMING COMMUNITY, THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND ALL THE CHALLENGES
THEY'RE HAVING TO ACCESS ENOUGH
WATER TO DO THEIR WORK. SO THIS
BOND WAS FRAMED WITH THAT IN
MIND EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. NOW,
YOU KNOW, I, I LIKE SOME LINE
ITEMS MORE THAN I LIKE OTHERS.
LET ME BE REAL HONEST. THIS IS
THE PRODUCT OF A LOT OF COOKS IN
THE KITCHEN. BUT I THINK THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
INVESTMENTS HERE ARE GOING TO BE
THINGS THAT, THAT, THAT, THAT
OUR CHILDREN WILL BE THANKING US
FOR. BUT I DO THINK IT'S GOING
TO TAKE SOME REALLY SMART AND
WISE MANAGEMENT AS WE GO
FORWARD. I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
INCLUDING REALLY SMART
ENGAGEMENT WITH WALL STREET,
AND, YOU KNOW, AND ALL THAT. I
WILL SAY ON SITES YOU BRING UP
SITES, I MEAN, THE BIGGEST
HOLDUP ON THAT HAS BEEN, YOU
KNOW, LOCAL COST MATCH. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED HERE. BUT I THINK, I
MEAN, FROM MY UNDERSTANDING, YOU
KNOW, ALMOST ALL OF THE 3
BILLION, IT WAS LIKE 2.8 BILLION
IN PROP ONE, HAS BEEN SPENT.
AND, WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
PROJECT. WE'RE STILL A MILLION,
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS AWAY FROM
GETTING IT ON THE GROUND. I
MEAN, THE GOVERNOR JUST TOOK OUT
500 MILLION OUT OF THIS BUDGET
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO GO TO
SITES. WELL, AND SITES, I MEAN,
I KNOW THEY JUST THERE'S JUST A
BIG STREAMLINING ON SEAQUEST
SOMEWHERE. THERE HAS TO BE A
QUESTION AND AN ANSWER. YEAH, AS
OPPOSED TO A COLLOQUY. SO I'M
GOING TO TAKE THAT AS A
QUESTION. AND WHY DON'T YOU DO A
FINAL ANSWER? OKAY. I MEAN, I
KNOW SO ON SITES WE STREAMLINED
SKILL REVIEW FOR SITES.
CHALLENGES WERE PROCESSED WITHIN
FOUR MONTHS SO THAT PROCESS IS
MOVING FORWARD, AND SO I MEAN, I
MEAN, EVERYTHING ALWAYS TAKES
TOO LONG AROUND HERE, BUT. WELL,
YEAH. OKAY SORRY, YOU KNOW, I
WANT TO WAIT TILL YOU'RE DONE.
NO, NO, SENATOR, PLEASE. OKAY.
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO MAKE A
COMMENT ABOUT THE FINANCING, BUT
I WILL MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT THAT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND ON
THE FINANCING, THE LET'S LOOK AT
THE GLOBAL PICTURE OF THE STATE
BUDGET. INVESTMENTS ARE FOR
THINGS YOU CAN'T DO THAT JUMP IT
AHEAD. AND THE MEASURE IS, IS
YOUR BONDED INDEBTEDNESS NOT
MORE THAN 5 TO 6% OF YOUR TOTAL
GENERAL FUND BUDGET? THIS IS
TOTALLY WITHIN IT. THAT IS WHY.
AND YOU MENTIONED THE SCHOOLS.
THE SCHOOLS IS LITERALLY JOBS.
IT IS INVESTMENTS. IT IS PEOPLE
THAT ARE WILL BE EMPLOYED FOR 40
OR 50 YEAR BUILDING OR REPAIR
JOB FOR SCHOOLS THAT WILL MATCH,
THE ENROLLMENT ON THIS BOND. AND
I JUST LOOK AT IT IN TERMS OF
THE CLIMATE CHANGED IN MY ADULT
LIFE. AND WE ARE TRYING TO DO
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT TO GET
AHEAD OF IT. IT'S, YOU KNOW,
BETTER THAN ANY OF US ABOUT
FIRE. AND WHEN I VISITED THE
DIXIE FIRE, THE PLACES THAT THEY
HAD CLEARED THE UNDERBRUSH, NOT
FAR FROM THE TOWN OF GREENVILLE
DID MUCH BETTER. AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE CCU FIRE IN MY DISTRICT,
THE PLACES THAT THEY WERE
PRESCRIBED BURNED OR UNDER BRUSH
CLEANING, THAT'S WHERE SOME OF
THE PEOPLE ATTRIBUTE THE FACT
THAT THEIR HOUSES SURVIVED TO
THAT. IT WAS TRUE IN THE FIRE
THAT JUMPED OVER CHRISTMAS
VALLEY IN THE TAHOE AREA. THERE
WERE CERTAIN BY ECHO SUMMIT
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND CLEANING
THAT SAFE HOUSES. THE FIRE
INVESTMENT HERE DOES THAT
STATEWIDE IN A WAY THAT IT DOES
THAT INVESTMENT AND TRIES TO
CATCH UP. I MEAN, THAT'S I THINK
THE I KNOW TO THAT THAT IS TRUE.
WITH THE SEA LEVEL RISE AND WHAT
GOES THERE BECAUSE IT HAS JUST
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY. I MEAN,
GIVEN THE FACT THAT I HAVE A
HIGHWAY THAT KEEPS FALLING IN
THE OCEAN AND HASN'T BEEN OPENED
ALL THE WAY THROUGH BIG SUR IN
18 MONTHS, EVEN THOUGH WE'RE ON
TARGET, WERE CLOSE. IT IS. HOW
DO WE LOOK AHEAD TO DO THAT? AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BOND DOES. AND
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER, WITH
WATER RECYCLING, WHICH IS
EVERYWHERE, THAT IS A CHANCE TO
HAVE A WATER SOURCE FOR
EVERYBODY, EVERYWHERE IN THE
STATE THAT DEALS WITH THE FACT
THAT THE SNOWPACK IS DECLINING,
PRECIPITATION PATTERNS ARE
CHANGING. THIS IS A SERIES OF
INVESTMENT THAT YOUR SON AND
GRANDCHILDREN, WHICH YOU HOPE
FOR, WILL ACTUALLY SEE. THEY
WILL SEE WITH THE LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT HERE. AND THAT'S WHY
WITHIN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S AVAILABLE IN THE BUDGET,
YOU MAKE. AND I JUST KNOW
THERE'S ONE LITTLE VILLAGE, SAN
LUCAS, IN MY DISTRICT, THAT HAS
WATER QUALITY PROBLEMS THAT FAR
OUTSTRIP THE ABILITY OF THE
PEOPLE THERE TO FUND IT. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO TO
YOU KNOW, WE MOVED FROM 1.6
MILLION PEOPLE WITHOUT SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN THE STATE TO 1
MILLION IN A RELATIVELY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME. BUT WE HAVE THAT
MILLION TO GO, AND WE HAVE MORE
IN JEOPARDY BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGING CLIMATE. THE INVESTMENT
LEVEL THAT IS HERE IS WHAT WILL
REALLY MAKE THAT DIFFERENCE. AND
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE FOR BOND INVESTORS
IN INDEBTEDNESS. IT IS WITHIN
THE PARAMETERS OF THE STATE
BUDGET, AND IT DOES LONG TERM
THINGS THAT WE WILL SEE THE
OUTCOMES OF. ALTHOUGH I SUSPECT
THIS IS A DISCUSSION WE WILL BE
HAVING HAVING IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS. AND SO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE HAS RETURNED EVERY
SINGLE MEMBER. WHILE YOU WERE
GONE, ASKED QUESTIONS AND SO,
THERE'S STILL PUBLIC COMMENT
UNLESS YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. AND
I'M GOING TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER
TO YOU NOW THAT WE HAVE A REAL
CHAIR. I'M JUST I'M JUST
KIDDING. YEAH. I'M I MOVE, WE
ADJOURN. I JUST WANT TO SAY I'M
NOT OPPOSED TO, LIKE I SAID ON
THE SENATE-TV VIDAK: CONSERVANCY
FOR SEVEN YEARS, AND WE DID DO A
LOT OF WORK. I'M NOT GOING TO
SAY THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE GOOD
WORK WITH BONDS. I'M GOING TO
CHALLENGE YOU THE WHOLE WAY
THROUGH, THOUGH, THAT WE THAT
YOU DEMONSTRATE TO THE PUBLIC
THAT WE'RE REALLY GOING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING HERE, AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO GET ON THE
GROUND STUFF ACCOMPLISHED
BECAUSE OUR TRACK RECORD, IN MY
OPINION, IS NOT THAT GREAT. AND
WE SPENT AND WE SPENT A LOT OF
RESOURCES. YEAH, WE CAN APPOINT
TO THOSE PROJECTS THAT WERE
GOOD. BUT THE BIG STATEWIDE
PROJECTS AND AS FAR AS FIRE
GOES, WE'VE DONE ABOUT
EVERYTHING YOU CAN DO. WE ONLY
CONTROL THE PRIVATE PROPERTY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE FEDS HAVE 60% OF
THE LAND BASE IN THE SIERRAS
THAT THIS IS NOT GOING TO
AFFECT. SO I JUST WANT TO THROW
THAT OUT. I JUST WANT TO THROW
THOSE THOSE THINGS OUT. SO I
WILL BE CHALLENGING THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY. AND
OUR TRACK RECORD, I DON'T
BELIEVE HAS BEEN THAT GREAT WHEN
IT COMES TO GIANT PROJECTS IN
THE STATE THAT WE ACTUALLY
DELIVER TO HELP OUT, YOU KNOW,
ALL OF CALIFORNIA, I TAKE IT
THAT WAS NOT A QUESTION, BUT A
COMMENT. WELL IT'S A CHALLENGE,
I THINK, FOR ALL OF US. IF THIS
THING PASSES FOR US TO DO THE
DUE DILIGENCE THAT IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AT THE END OF THE
SENTENCE, LET'S PUT IT THAT.
THANK YOU. I GUESS I'LL JUST
FOLLOW UP. FIRST, JUST BY NOTING
THAT, THANK YOU TO SENATOR
LEONARD FOR TAKING OVER THE
GAVEL. I WAS GONE. I MEAN, I'M
GOING TO ECHO HIS COMMENTS. AND,
YOU KNOW, WE TAKE OUT HOME
MORTGAGES BECAUSE THAT'S A LARGE
UPFRONT COST FOR SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED. WE NEED HOUSING, RIGHT?
WE TAKE OUT CERTAIN FORMS OF
LONG TERM DEBT BECAUSE WE HAVE
LONG TERM CHALLENGES. AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE KNOW RIGHT
NOW, AND I THINK THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS KNOW AND STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
CERTAIN LONG TERM CHALLENGES,
BOTH BECAUSE WE HAVE FAILED TO
INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE OVER
THE LAST 50 YEARS IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY IN THIS STATE AND
IN THIS COUNTRY, BUT ALSO
BECAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE IS POSING
MASSIVE CHALLENGES TO OUR BASIC
WAY OF LIFE. AND I THINK IT IS
NOT A PARTIZAN POINT. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY
BELIEVES IN THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS FIRE RISK AND WATER
CONSERVATION NEEDS RIGHT NOW,
AND TO DO THAT UP FRONT WOULD
TAKE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
FROM OUR GENERAL FUND MONEY THAT
WE DON'T HAVE. SO I APPLAUD
SENATOR DALY'S POINT ABOUT
OVERSIGHT AND TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THE MONEY GETS OUT THE DOOR
IN AN EFFICIENT AND THOUGHTFUL
WAY. AND CERTAINLY WE ALWAYS
WANT GOVERNMENT SPENDING TO BE
EFFICIENT. BUT THIS STRIKES ME
AS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
THERE'S LARGE AGREEMENT ON THAT
WE NEED RIGHT NOW THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS. AND I'VE HEARD SOME
OF YOUR YOUR SOLILOQUIES ON THE
FLOOR, SENATOR DALY, ABOUT THE
NEED TO ADDRESS FIRE RISK, ABOUT
THE NEED TO ADDRESS OUR WATER
CONCERNS HERE IN THE STATE. SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE DO THAT
WITHOUT A BOND. I THINK THIS IS
APPROPRIATE. I JUST ALSO NOTE
THAT WE DON'T. WE'RE NOT HERE TO
DISCUSS THE EDUCATION, BOND AND
WHATEVER ISSUES WE MIGHT HAVE
WITH THAT BOND OR ANYTHING ELSE
ARE OUTSIDE OF THE SCOPE OF THIS
HEARING. SO I GUESS WITH THAT,
YOU KNOW, MAYBE YOU'D LIKE TO
RESPOND, SENATOR ALLEN OR ANY OF
THE OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
PANEL. YEAH. I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY,
I AGREE WITH YOU. I MEAN, WE
WE'VE WE DO. I WILL SAY BY
HISTORICAL STANDARDS, THE EXTENT
OF OUR CURRENT, DEBT SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS IS ACTUALLY PRETTY
LOW. I MEAN, THERE WAS A POINT,
I THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S IN THE
THREES. THERE WAS A POINT IT WAS
ALMOST 9% ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO,
THIS THIS WOULD PUT US AT, YOU
KNOW, IN THE FIVES WITHIN ABOUT
25, 26. AND THEN IT'LL COME DOWN
FROM THERE IF WE, IF WE DO ALL
THREE OF THE BONDS, ALL THREE,
SO THERE'S THE CAPACITY, IS
THERE. WE SHOULDN'T GO INTO THIS
LIGHTLY. I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
YOU ON THAT. AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY YOUR, YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS REALLY ARE, IF
ANYTHING, A ADMONITION TO THE
PEOPLE AROUND THE TABLE TO
ENSURE THAT IF WE DO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS, WE'RE GOING
TO WE'RE GOING TO REALLY WORK
HARD TO ENSURE THAT THAT THE
DOLLARS ARE WELL SPENT AND THAT
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON DOING
RIGHT BY FUTURE GENERATIONS IN
THESE INVESTMENTS. AND THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S, I THINK, AT THE
HEART OF WHAT YOU'RE ARGUING.
AND I DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT
AT ALL. I PASSIONATELY AGREE
WITH IT, BUT I'D LOVE TO HEAR I
KNOW WE AND LET ME TURN THAT
INTO AN ACTUAL QUESTION, WHICH
IS, IN THE ABSENCE OF THIS BOND,
MAYBE YOU COULD KIND OF PROVIDE
A COMPARISON OF WHAT OUR FIRE
PREVENTION AND WATER
CONSERVATION EFFORTS AND FLOOD
PREVENTION EFFORTS MIGHT LOOK
LIKE IF WE DON'T GET THIS BOND
PASSED. I CAN JUST START BY
SAYING THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THE FUNDING IS GOING TO COME TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING DRINKING
WATER PROGRAMS APACE, IN A FEW
YEARS. OUTGOING. AND THAT MEANS
THE RESIDENTS THAT WE'RE
ORGANIZING WITH ARE GOING TO
KEEP DRINKING WATER THAT IS
CONTAMINATED BY NITRATES, AND
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP TAKING
SHOWERS THAT ARE GOING TO CAUSE
CANCER BECAUSE THERE'S ONE, TWO,
THREE TCP. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
THESE SMALL PROJECTS, THESE
CONSOLIDATIONS SINCE SAFER'S
BEEN ENACTED, THE WATER BOARD
HAS GOTTEN OVER 100
CONSOLIDATIONS DONE. WE NEED
RESOURCES TO KEEP THEM GOING.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT, WE'RE
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT HOW WE CAN
KEEP GETTING THAT MILLION NUMBER
DOWN. AND IN TIME, IN ORDER TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN A LOT OF
FOLKS LIVES. YEAH. AND I'LL JUST
MENTION AND REITERATE WHAT I
SAID IN MY TESTIMONY THAT
HISTORICALLY, WE HAVE FUNDED OUR
NATURAL RESOURCE PROGRAMS
THROUGH GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS. AND YOU'LL SEE A PEAK
WHEN WE GET SOME FUNDING FROM
THESE BONDS. AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
WE GO DOWN TO REALLY LOW NUMBERS
OF THE TOTAL PERCENTAGE OF THE
STATE BUDGET THAT IS DEDICATED
TO NATURAL RESOURCES. SO THESE
BONDS ARE HOW WE FUND THESE
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
BEFORE WE ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE, I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. UNLESS THERE'S
ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM ANYONE ON THE DAIS, NOT
ANYONE A MEMBER. SORRY A MEMBER.
THANK YOU. JOHN. WITH THAT, I,
WE WILL WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME, EACH
COMMENT WILL BE LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE EACH. THAT DOES INCLUDE
JOKES SO THAT LONGER THAN I
THOUGHT. ONE MINUTE, ONE MINUTE.
I'M SORRY. ONE MINUTE, MY NAME
IS ALFREDO ARREDONDO. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT, AS WELL AS THE
YUBA COUNTY WATER AGENCY, BOTH
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL AND
VERY ESPECIALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE DAM SAFETY FUNDING AND
RESILIENCE FUNDING. THAT'S
THAT'S MADE AVAILABLE ON THE
BOND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. KENDRA HARRIS WITH
THE CLIMATE CENTER. I JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RICO MASTRODONATO
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND
OFFERING OUR SUPPORT AND ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND. I
COULDN'T SAY IT BETTER THAN THE
CHAIRMAN DID. WE'RE NOT KEEPING
UP WITH THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND THE PLANET IS
GETTING HOTTER, AND THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE WE CAN DO ABOUT THAT. AND
LAST YEAR WAS THE HOTTEST YEAR
ON RECORD THIS PAST APRIL. AND
MAY WERE THE HOTTEST MONTHS OF
MAY AND APRIL EVER ON RECORD,
AND THIS IS GOING TO KEEP
GETTING WORSE AND MORE
PROLONGED. IF WE DO NOT HAVE
THIS BOND, WE WILL FALL EVEN
FURTHER BEHIND IN PROTECTING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES FROM
HEAT AND FLOODING. AND OUR, IN
ADDITION TO THE 800 MILES OF
COAST THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND ALL THE PEOPLE THAT WORKED
ON THIS IN THE SENATE. AND THANK
YOU, CHAIRMAN, AND, STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, TERRY MCHALE
WITH AARON REED. AND ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL
2881. IN 30 YEARS OF DOING THIS,
WHAT I'VE DISCOVERED IS THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN. WE NEED ALL THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS WORKING TOGETHER.
AND I THINK THAT SENATOR ALLEN
HAS DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB OF
BRINGING EVERYONE UNDER THE SAME
ROOF. I DO SHARE SENATOR
DONNELLY'S CONCERN THAT THE
MONEY BE SPENT APPROPRIATELY,
AND I DO THINK THAT THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS WITHIN THIS THAT CAN
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS. BUT
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR THEIR
HARD WORK. ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. AND IT'S DAILY. I
LEARNED THAT JUST TWO WEEKS AGO,
GOOD AFTERNOON PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST, ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND THE OTHER
FOLKS THAT WERE INVOLVED. ECHO A
LOT OF THE COMMENTS FROM THE
DÍAS THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
CRITICAL THAT WE SPEND THIS
MONEY STRATEGICALLY AND
EFFECTIVELY. IT'S A LOT OF
MONEY, AND WE'RE GOING TO TURN
AROUND. IT'S GOING TO BE NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH MONEY AS WE'RE
LOOKING BACK AT WHAT WE SHOULD
HAVE INVESTED TEN YEARS FROM
NOW. SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU, MICHAEL. JARED, ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS, THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
CLIMATE RESOLVE, IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL, WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE INVESTMENTS, INCLUDING THE
INVESTMENTS FOR SUSTAINABLE AG,
PROTECTION OF BIODIVERSITY AND
EXTREME HEAT. THANK YOU. HI,
ANNALISE RIVERO ON BEHALF OF CAL
TROUT AND TROUT UNLIMITED HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS, WITH
PARTICULAR APPRECIATION FOR THE
DAM REMOVAL FUNDING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, NICHOLAS MAZZOTTI,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS, IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR, IN PARTICULAR, WE'D LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND OTHERS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH ON THE
PROVISION AROUND STATE CERTIFIED
LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
JULIE WIECKOWSKI, ON BEHALF OF
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR MEMBERS. KAYLA ROBINSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE LAND TRUST OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND EVERYONE
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS AND
FOR COMING TOGETHER TO GET A
CLIMATE BOND TOGETHER. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. HELLO, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS KAI COOPER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU, KIM SNYDER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO, PLACER COUNTY WATER
AGENCY, SACRAMENTO AREA SEWER
DISTRICT, NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM
OF LA COUNTY, SAN DIEGO ZOO,
WILDLIFE ALLIANCE, CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES, CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL,
MOUNTAINS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY, AND
OUTWARD BOUND ADVENTURES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. MARK MASON,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. WE JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS. FOR CONTEXT, WE
WERE PART OF THE CLIMATE BOND
NOW COALITION, WHICH OUR SHARED
PRIORITIES FOR ABOUT 180
ORGANIZATIONS WERE AROUND 23
BILLION. SO WE THINK A $10
BILLION BOND IS KIND OF THE
STARTING POINT. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE EFFORTS OVER
THE PAST MONTHS TO RIGHTSIZE
THIS TO MAKE IT HAPPEN. THANKS
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. LEE O'KEEFE
WITH CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY, ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OUR 36
CHAPTERS, WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND GRATITUDE FOR THE
WORK ON THIS. THANK YOU. IS WITH
AZUL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MEAGAN MURRAY WITH THE WHITMAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF R-WI AND
STRONG SUPPORT, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENTS IN
PORT INFRASTRUCTURE
PARTICULARLY. THANK YOU. HI.
SAMANTHA SAMUELSON, ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSERVATION FUND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ABIGAIL SMITH, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION AND
SEMPERVIRENS FUND AND STRONG
SUPPORT AND ESPECIALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROVISIONS FOR
STATE PARKS FUNDING. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. HI THERE, MEGAN
MICKELBERG. ON BEHALF OF CAL
VANS, WHICH IS THE VANPOOL
AUTHORITY THAT PROVIDES
FARMWORKER TRANSPORTATION TO AND
FROM WORK FROM THEIR HOMES.
THERE'S 15 MILLION IN THERE,
WHICH WE REALLY, REALLY
APPRECIATE. ALSO JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND
SAY A STRONG SUPPORT FROM ABOUT
75 OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE
ALSO SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
READ ADUS ON BEHALF OF SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE. THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WORK ON
THIS. IT'S DESPERATELY NEEDED
WITHOUT THIS BOND PASSING THE
PROJECTS WE'RE WORKING ON WILL
COME TO A HALT AT THE END OF THE
YEAR, SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CYNTHIA CORTEZ WITH RESTORE THE
DELTA. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS AND ALSO WANT TO SAY
THAT THE BOND PROVIDES ESSENTIAL
FUNDING FOR FLOOD PROTECTION,
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION AND
SUPPORT FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TAYLOR
OCEAN, ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
AFFAIRS ALLIANCE AND WESTERN
AFFAIRS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE FAIR INFRASTRUCTURE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. AARON NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE ALMOND ALLIANCE,
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR THANKS TO
THE SENATOR AND THE SENATE
WORKING GROUP FOR ALL OF THE
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE ON THIS
BOND. WE'RE REALLY PLEASED TO
SEE THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN
THERE FOR WATER PROJECTS, NAMELY
GROUNDWATER QUALITY AND SUPPLY.
AND ALMOND ALLIANCE HAS
PARTNERED WITH, OUR PARTNERS AT
WESTERN UNITED DAIRIES AND DWR
ON AN INNOVATIVE PROGRAM CALLED
LAND FLEX, WHICH IS HELPFUL IN
TIMES OF FLOOD AND DROUGHT, AND
PROTECTS THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE IN DANGER OF OVERDRAFTED
BASINS AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT IF
THE BOND MOVES FORWARD, THAT, WE
RECEIVE SOME FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, JENNIFER
CAPETILLO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING WATER
UTILITIES REGULATED BY THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ALAN. STAFF,
EVERYONE WHO WORKED ON THIS,
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD ME TALK
ABOUT IT. OTHERS TALK ABOUT IT.
OUR NATION AT LARGE IS VERY MUCH
BEHIND AND REPLACING NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR DRINKING
WATER. SO THIS WILL GO A LONG
WAY IN HELPING GET US WHERE WE
NEED TO BE. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. ON BEHALF
OF INVENERGY, ALSO KNOWN AS AVON
WIND IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
DELTA COUNTY COALITION, A BIG
THANK YOU TO SENATOR ALLEN AND
THE LEGISLATURE FOR PASSING, YOU
KNOW, SEEKING TO PASS THIS BOND.
THESE FUNDS ARE NOTHING SHORT OF
CRITICAL FOR DELTA MAINTENANCE.
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THIS AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DAN SHAW,
ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH, STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
OFFSHORE PORT OFFSHORE WIND PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE MONIES, WHICH
WILL LEAD TO A SIGNIFICANT
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN TERMS OF
GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS AND THE
LONG TERM RELIABILITY OF THE
GRID. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. KIM
DELFINO, ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE, THE SONOMA LAND
TRUST, MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST,
SIERRA FOREST LEGACY SIERRA
FUND, SIERRA INSTITUTE, GOLDEN
STATE SALMON ASSOCIATION, PEW
CHARITABLE TRUST, OCEANA, OCEAN
CONSERVANCY, MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM, AND NRDC. I THINK IT'S
FAIRLY OBVIOUS WHY WE'D BE
SUPPORTING THIS BOND AND
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK BY THE
WORKING MEMBERS, BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND URGE, AND I VOTE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
, KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE COUNTY BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS
OF RIVERSIDE AND VENTURA
COUNTIES HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MELISSA SPARKS KRANZ
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES. WE HAD A SUPPORTIVE
AMEND POSITION ON SB 867, AND WE
ARE REALLY PLEASED WITH THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
HAS GONE INTO THE BOND, WE ARE A
BIT SADDENED TO NOT SEE FUNDING
FOR ORGANIC WASTE REMOVAL FROM
LANDFILLS TO REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS, AS WELL AS
TRANSITIONING PUBLIC VEHICLES TO
CLEAN FLEET. BUT WE WILL KEEP
CHARGING FORWARD WITH THOSE
CLIMATE INITIATIVES, AND WE ARE
EXTREMELY, EXTREMELY PLEASED TO
SEE FUNDING FOR STORM WATER,
WATER RECYCLING, WATER
CONSERVATION, WILDFIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS FOR LOCALS,
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES, SEA
LEVEL RISE, EXTREME HEAT AND
PARKS FUNDING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. JAMIE, GO ON
BEHALF OF RESOURCES LEGACY FUND.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND JUST WANTED TO THANK
THE SENATE, SENATOR ALLEN, FOR
THE LEADERSHIP IN MAKING SURE
THAT THIS COMES TOGETHER. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HELPING MAKE
SURE IT GETS ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
SENATORS, MATTHEW BAKER,
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE I
JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK OF THE MANY INTERESTS THAT
WENT IN TO BRINGING THIS FORWARD
. AND THANK YOU. STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MELISSA
CORTEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION, WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR, THE WORKING GROUPS AND
ALL THE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK
ON THIS IN SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY
OF THE FUNDING FOR THE PORTS,
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED IF WE WANT TO
ACTUALLY DEVELOP OFFSHORE WIND,
THIS IS THE NEXT CRITICAL STEP.
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
FUNDING FOR TRANS TRANSMISSION.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS ABOUT THE NEED
FOR TRANSMISSION IF WE'RE GOING
TO ACTUALLY MEET OUR GOALS. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THANK YOU
. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MARK
FENSTERMAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LAND TRUSTS,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS,
PENINSULA OPEN SPACE TRUST, BIG
SUR LAND TRUST AND SONOMA WATER
REALLY WANT TO THANK SENATOR
ALLEN, HIS STAFF, EVERYBODY
WHO'S WORKED SO HARD ON THIS
BOND FOR MANY YEARS NOW TO GET
US TO THIS POINT, WE OBVIOUSLY
NEED IT. THE COMMENTS FROM
EVERYBODY WHO SPOKE BEFORE ME
HAVE LAID OUT HOW IMPERATIVE
THIS IS. SO WE REALLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AS WE GO FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MISTER CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JONATHAN CLAY HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO, SUPPORT FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS, BUT MAIN ONE
FOR US AS A REGION IN SAN DIEGO
IS THE CROSS BORDERS AND THE
BORDER RIVERS FUNDING, WHICH IS
VERY NEEDED FOR OUR PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE DOING ALONG THE
TIJUANA RIVER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, REBECCA MARQUEZ,
REPRESENTING THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT,
AS WELL AS THE FOOD AND FARM
RESILIENCE COALITION, THE
SPONSORS OF ASSEMBLY, WILSON'S
AB 408, A COALITION OF 17
AGRICULTURE, FARMWORKER,
ENVIRONMENTAL, PUBLIC HEALTH AND
FOOD SECURITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATORS ROSANNA
CARAVAGGIO ELLIOTT HERE ON
BEHALF OF ECUADOR, WHICH IS AN
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPER, THEY
HAVE A LEASE OFF THE CENTRAL
COAST OF CALIFORNIA. APPRECIATE
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT WENT INTO
THIS. SOMEONE SAID FOR NUMEROUS
YEARS AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT IN PORTS, WHICH, AS
WAS STATED EARLIER, IS GOING TO
BE NEEDED TO ACTUALLY GET
OFFSHORE WIND GOING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE, I WILL JUST REMARK
THAT THAT WAS A REMARKABLY
EFFICIENT SET OF PRESENTATIONS
AND MAYBE A GOOD SIGN OF THE
EFFICIENCY OF THIS BOND SHOULD
IT GET PASSED, WITH THAT, I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR ALLEN AND THE
PANELISTS FOR PROVIDING THEIR
OVERVIEW OF THE WATER AND
WILDFIRE BOND. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO OFFERED PUBLIC
COMMENT DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD, PROUD TO BE A
COAUTHOR OF THIS PARTICULAR BOND
ACT. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO A
MORE ROBUST DISCUSSION TOMORROW
WHEN THIS MEASURE IS TAKEN UP ON
THE SENATE FLOOR. WITH THAT
WOULD ANY OF YOU LIKE TO MAKE
ANY CLOSING REMARKS, ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE DAIS, OR
SENATOR ALLEN? SENATOR ALLEN,
NO, I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH ALL
THE DISCUSSION AND ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS. I
CERTAINLY DON'T TAKE THIS WORK
LIGHTLY, AND I DON'T TAKE THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY MY COLLEAGUE LIGHTLY, WE DO
KNOW WE'VE GOT ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES ON OUR HANDS, AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE COSTLY. AND
I MEAN, THIS WHOLE THING WAS
CRAFTED WITH A MIND TOWARD
PUTTING UP IN PLACE UPFRONT
INVESTMENTS. NOW, THAT WILL THAT
WILL HELP US BETTER PREPARE FOR
THE ENORMOUS CHALLENGES OF THE
FUTURE. THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ULTIMATELY ALL ABOUT, AND I'M,
I'M REALLY HOPEFUL THAT NOT ONLY
WE'LL BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
MAKE THE CASE TO OUR COLLEAGUES,
BUT ALSO TO OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS THAT THIS IS A
WORTHWHILE SET OF INVESTMENTS.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE LIFE BETTER
IN THE FUTURE, AND I HOPE WE'RE
ALL GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS AND GET THIS THING PASSED
IN NOVEMBER. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALLEN, WITH THAT, THIS JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.